There's nothing worse than making a faux pas on a business trip.
And honestly, I've a lot of questions about etiquette.
There's only one thing to do.
I'm here with an etiquette expert Julie Hirst to get some answers, finally.
Now Julie, who gets the tip in the hotel and how do we leave that to?
Everybody who provides a service.
So, let's say it's a valet.
You're pulling up,...
...you tip the person who was opening the door for you one to two dollars.
Okay.
And then you have the porter or the bellman...
...and he too gets one to two dollars per bag.
Per bag?
Per bag, correct.
Well actually, I've just been clued in for today's interview...
...is that people get tips like maids.
It is customary to leave three dollars per night.
And you would put it, if there's an envelope provided for you,...
...then it goes in that envelope.
If there's not, then you will pull out your envelope...
...and put housekeeping or the housekeeper's name...
...and then leave it on the desk.
What do I do about the guilt that I'm feeling...
...that I have stayed in so many hotels in my life and didn't know that?
Any thoughts?
Well, you could go back to all the hotels you've stayed at and say, "I'm so sorry!"
You go back and look at season one,...
...that is 40-something hotels from Boston to Los Angeles.
So, coming up on season three of "The Smart Show,"...
...Henry making up for his faux pas...
...from coast-to-coast, hotel to hotel, making up for what he's done wrong.
But from here on now, now you know.
You are now socially savvy to go out and travel the proper way.
And so there are no more excuses.
Julie, thank you so much!
Thank you!